Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
después de los terremotos en Turquía y
Siria son incalculables las
consecuencias miles quedaron sin hogar
entre ellos familias que ya habían
tenido que desplazarse por una guerra
civil que los alejó de su país Turquía
es la nación que acoge el mayor número
de personas refugiadas en el mundo y una
gran cantidad provienen de su vecina
Siria en las regiones afectadas por los
sismos hay refugiados que volvieron a
perderlo todo e incluso a algunos de sus
seres queridos Cuál es su situación en
medio de este devastador evento
geológico lo vemos en el siguiente
informe
una vez más esta refugiada Siria y su
familia tuvieron que dejar su hogar pero
ahora no por causa de un conflicto los
terremotos en Turquía del pasado 6 de
febrero dejaron su casa en ruinas y a su
familia sin techo su único Refugio son
estos vehículos ellos repiten una
historia que ya conocen
[Música]
bien paz en mi país de origen Siria y
luego sucedieron varias cosas estalló la
guerra hubo muchos bombardeos y vivíamos
en continua ansiedad
lanzaron muchos ataques en el área en el
que estábamos huimos de allí y luego
compramos una nueva casa en la misma
zona pero los bombardeos siguieron hubo
enfrentamientos y destrucción Y huimos
de nuevo
vivimos en los suburbios mientras
esperábamos nuestros documentos y
llegamos a Turquía en un barco a través
del Líbano
nuevamente alya tendrá que buscar
refugio y el futuro vuelve a ser una
gran incógnita
en la ciudad turca de antioquía está ong
ayuda a los sirios que llevan días a la
intemperie y resistiendo gélidas
temperaturas terremoto les volvió a
cambiar la vida pero ahora en solo unos
minutos
la mala experiencia en la ciudad de
sirias se prolongó durante años lo
bombardeos la destrucción y la guerra
destruir a lepo se boa años aquí una
ciudad que acogía a turcos y a
refugiados Fue totalmente destruida en
tres minutos la vida se paralizó de
inmediato no hay servicios ni luz ni
agua ni infraestructura y ningún lugar
es habitable pero pese a las difíciles
condiciones muchos de los que están aquí
se negaron a evacuar porque mantienen la
esperanza de reencontrarse con sus
familiares Mientras tanto reciben
alimentos y cobijo
en el sureste de Turquía en Villar
vaquir vivían unos 25 mil refugiados
sirios después de los sismos una
mezquita le sirve de temporal
[Música]
el terremoto es peor que la guerra
porque sucedió de repente
estábamos durmiendo y sucedió de repente
cuando hay guerras sabemos De antemano
nos escondemos en sótanos montañas o
desiertos el terremoto nos sorprendió
no pudimos correr ni hacer nada salimos
simplemente
familias sirias que reconstruyeron su
vida en Turquía tendrán que volver a
empezar muchas sin alguno de sus
integrantes
a medida que los días revelaban la
magnitud de la tragedia por los
terremotos también aumentaron las
denuncias sobre ataques contra los
sirios en Turquía en el terreno aseguran
que algunos ciudadanos turcos no ven con
buenos ojos la ayuda dada a los
extranjeros nuestro enviado especial a
las zonas más afectadas Adrián Rocha nos
reportó al respecto
el terremoto del pasado lunes por la
madrugada en el sur este de Turquía y el
noroeste de Siria ha afectado dos zonas
especialmente
sensibles en lo que respecta a los
refugiados sirios porque el noroeste de
Siria es un lugar lleno desplazados
internos por culpa de conflicto y el
sureste de Turquía es la zona dentro de
Turquía en la que habitan más refugiados
sirios y esto ha provocado muchísimos
inconvenientes para esta población sobre
todo porque Durante los últimos años el
racismo de los turcos se encuentran los
sirios a los que acusan de la crisis
económica que vivía hasta hace poco y
sigue viviendo el país Turco los
refugiados sirios son acusados de todo
tipo de crímenes como de supuestamente
robar de dentro de tiendas y de acaparar
tiendas de campaña de hecho nos
explicaba una refugiada Siria Hace unos
días que sus vecinos turcos en un campo
de refugiados como este creado por el
por el terremoto la acusaban de tener
una tienda de campaña cuando había
turcos que no la tenían ella explicaba
que también había perdido su casa la su
vivienda su familia sus familiares y que
sin embargo la acusaban y le
perseguían cuando ella iba a buscar
comida de la ayuda que llegaba que sin
embargo sí que le estaba llegando a ella
y a muchos más sin embargo por las redes
sociales los mensajes de odio en contra
sobre todo la población Siria han
aumentado muchísimo también a través de
la creación de un partido abiertamente
racista en Turquía es el partido de la
lectura es hacer Party sí que está
haciendo Campaña en ir a estos sitios de
refugiados y a intentar sacar ellos
mismos los refugiados de los lugares hay
muchos que temen que la situación se
podría tensar a un nivel tan alto que en
los próximos días o semanas podríamos
vivir incluso escenas no en solo un
sitio sino en varios sitios de violencia
comunal
ante las necesidades de los sirios en
Turquía doblemente desplazados por un
conflicto y ahora por un terremoto no es
Clara Cuál será la ayuda para ellos por
parte de los organismos internacionales
Cuál será la respuesta para la atención
humanitaria de Los refugiados afectados
por Los Fuertes movimientos de tierra
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]